'icarly was one of Nickelodeon's most
successful TV series but did the stars
of the show find success after
production wrapped up in 2012 or did
life have other plans for them keep
watching to find out which cast members
are still acting today and which one's
got typecasted and were forced to stop
acting all together watch until the very
end to find out which star switched her
focus to voice acting and became a
staple in the industry Jerry Trainor
played the gullible and hilarious
Spencer Shay on iCarly as I Carly's
older brother Spencer often acted as her
legal guardian considering that their
dad was in the military and their mother
was never mentioned Jerry has been
acting since the early 2000s and the end
of iCarly did not mark the end of his
acting career although Jerry has never
been cast in a Hollywood movie or a
celebrated TV series he is yet to throw
in his acting towel most recently Jerry
has been cast in the upcoming film
Renaissance Girl which is in its
pre-production phase as of March 2020
from 2016 to 2017
Jerry starred as Reggie in 10 episodes
of still the king
although Jerry has continued to pursue
acting he has yet to reinvent his image
and has been type casted into the
family-friendly genre Spencer yes little
larry lies-a-lot
mery played Marissa on iCarly the nosy
and overbearing mother of Freddie Benson
she was hilarious in her own right
despite being a hypochondriac who valued
safety above everything else which
you've already given me 11 shots mary
has been acting since the late 80s so
starring on iCarly
wasn't her first time at the rodeo did
you know that Mary start on the
hilarious improv show MADtv for a total
of three seasons or that she voiced Suzy
from the hare arnold cartoon franchise
for six long years obviously mary has
had a long and successful acting career
and icarly only helped her to get more
recognition on top of appearing in a
single episode of salmon cat and two
Broke Girls Mary would go on to portray
GLaDOS in the Disney Channel show bunk'd
Mary doesn't have anything in the works
for 20/20 but it's only a matter of time
before she resurfaces Gibby Gib soon was
portrayed by after Noah Munck who made
us laugh uncontrollably every single
time he ripped off his shirt for no
apparent reason he was a regular on
iCarly's web show and quite frankly the
show wouldn't have been the same without
him I just found out I'm too old about
two years after icarly aired its final
season Noah got the opportunity of a
lifetime when he was cast as Rob Smith
in the TV series the Goldbergs Noah's
character often goes by the name of
naked Rob on the show like most of the
icarly cast Noah would go on to reprise
his role as Gibby Gib sin on a single
episode of salmon cat
but before joining the icarly family
Noah was cast in movies like four
Christmases and bad teacher where he got
to act alongside household names like
Reese Witherspoon and Cameron Diaz the
sky's the limit for this hilarious actor
and we can't wait to see where he pops
up next I say
next up is Noah's little brother Ethan
monk who played Gibby's younger brother
guppy on iCarly
just like Gibby Cappy had a reputation
of ripping off his shirt whenever the
going got rough shirt down as of 2020
Eaton is 16 years old and is in high
school although he hasn't been in as
many productions as his older brother he
has managed to land a few roles since
icarly wrapped up production in 2012
most recently in 2019
Ethan was cast as James in the league of
legend capers shadows and in 2018 he was
cast in Shrek retold alongside Noah
Ethan portrayed donkey whereas Noah
played Shrek apart from that Ethan was
cast in a single episode of the new girl
in 2015 the young star doesn't have any
projects lined up as of 2020 but we
wouldn't be surprised if he becomes a
household name once he matures and
starts auditioning for different types
of roles nathan kress is the actor who
brought Freddie Benson to life on the
set of iCarly he was the administrator
for the icarly web site and helped the
web show come to fruition too bad we
don't know a thing has been up to a lot
since parting ways with the icarly cast
he married his best friend London Elise
in 2015 and they now have a daughter
together nathan has struggled to find a
long-lasting role since starring in the
Nickelodeon classic but in 2016 things
started to change for the actor when he
switched his focus from acting to voice
acting from 2016 to 2017 Nathan voiced
the character wedge in the animated
series Star Wars rebels then from 2018
to 2019 he voiced KK Jamison and
hoverboard man on pinky malinki Nathan
seems to be taking some time off to
focus on his family he has not been cast
in any upcoming projects as of early
2020 she couldn't be nicer to me if she
tried cause she has no self-control
after the success of iCarly Nickelodeon
chose to give jennette mccurdy 's
character Sam Puckett another go in the
TV show Sam and cat
which starred ariana grande however
things got a little messy when racy
pictures of Jeanette surfaced online
which hurt Jeanette's image Sam and cat
was cancelled after just one season but
she managed to bounce back after a
couple of years I got hungry before
lunch and after lunch we wouldn't say
that our Carly ruined Jeanette's acting
career but starring on the show is still
one of the actors biggest
accomplishments Jenna tried her hand in
short films for a couple of years
however she got little recognition from
them she starred as wily in the TV
series between from 2015 to 2016 but the
show soon got cancelled jennette always
had a love for directing and she finally
directed a short film called strong
independent women in 2019 the movie is
about a young woman who is trying to
overcome an eating disorder which is
something Jeanette has had to do herself
she hasn't been cast in any movies or TV
show since 2018 however she has created
her own one-woman show called I'm glad
my mom died which she performs for live
audiences her show is sold out and
Jeanette could not be happier how would
you like to see me do a really neat
magic trick with this bottle next up is
Reed Alexander the actor who played
Nevel papperman
the owner of nevelocity.com this web
critic was everyone's worst nightmare on
iCarly Neville was a smart guy but he
was also super arrogant despite his many
failed attempts to get Carly to kiss him
once the series came to an end in 2012
Reed found it difficult to stay afloat
in the acting industry in 2016 he was
cast in the Northland der Fidesz of 2019
Reed has yet to pop up into any new
productions from 2012 to 2019 Reed
guest-starred a handful of times on The
Today Show but apart from that it looks
like Reed's career as an actor has
fallen flat Reed went to Columbia
Journalism school and graduated in 2020
he's the author of cool
it's cookbook and spends most of his
time traveling the world I know a lot of
things about a lot of things actor Tim
Russ portrayed principal Franklin on the
show he was a successful actor before
joining the icarly family and he has
gone on to accomplish some truly amazing
things to say that Tim keeps himself
busy would be an understatement although
he isn't known for snagging long-lasting
roles he appears in dozens of
productions every single year in 2019
Tim had small roles in shows like
American Horror Story and how to get
away with murder unlike many of his
former cast members Tim is fully booked
for 2020 in fact he's currently cast in
seven different shows and movies most of
which are still in their post-production
phase why did you fail the quiz
Bobby Bowman aka bogey is well known for
playing the odd yet hilarious groovy
smoothie worker on iCarly boogie
appeared in a total of 25 episodes and
although he wasn't the most prominent
figure he was pretty close to the iCarly
trio which makes him a legend in our
book he played the role of Tebow a man
who was obsessed with serving food on a
stick but you put the stick through the
sides
this is embarrassing
unfortunately for boogie his acting
career seemed to hit a wall after icarly
aired its final episode in 2015 he would
be cast as filly in the TV series a
gamers guide to pretty much everything
he would appear in a total of six
episodes and that would be the last time
he was cast as an actor like many of his
fellow cast members acting on iCarly is
still seen as one of his biggest
accomplishments see it's impossible
lewbert sign was one of the most
despicable characters on iCarly
although he didn't appear in every
single episode he definitely made a
lasting impression Lewbert was played by
actor Jeremy Rolly who is also a writer
having recently worked on bless the
hearts Jeremy did an amazing job of
portraying the disgustingly insane
doorman of the bushwell plaza
this is where Carly and Freddie lived
for the duration of the show since
parting ways with Nickelodeon Jeremy
managed to land a few one-off roles in
TV shows like nobodies Munson is obese
and Mike Tyson mysteries although Jeremy
has not had the most successful acting
career since appearing on the icarly
show yes which just focused her writing
and voice acting he now voices a handful
of characters on bless the hearts on top
of writing for the show we first
encountered miranda cosgrove in 2003
when she was cast in the hilarious movie
School of Rock
then from 2004 to 2007 Miranda played
Megan Parker on the lively TV show Drake
and Josh and when that ended Nickelodeon
chose to give Miranda her very own show
icarly was a total hit but despite being
a household name are in defined it hard
to land new roles after icarly came to
an end this was frustrating for the
actor who has been in the limelight
since she was just a kid luckily for
Miranda she had been hired to voice
Margo in the despicable Me franchise in
2010 which would go on to have mini
installments this franchise helped
miranda stay current in the
ever-changing acting world apart from
voice acting Miranda loves to dance and
has appeared in music videos like
marshmallows happier and Pharrell
Williams happy in 2020 Miranda was cast
as Rachel in the movie North Hollywood
but apart from that she's choosing to
focus on her studies and that's a wrap
before you go tell us who your favorite
icarly actor is in the comments below
and be sure to tell us if you'd rather
see miranda --there in an iCarly or
Drake & Josh reboot what and why the
simultaneous
sois thanks for watching subscribe to
the themes for more great content and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time